the ignite X gs6 is one of the most
complete and useful kits for car owners
and homeowners that I have ever seen
they reached out to us and wanted us to
do a Showcase of all of these tools so
we said go ahead and send it over and
once I open this up I was shocked at how
well these are put together now inside
of here we have a variety of tools the
first thing that caught my attention is
the jump starter but we also have a
vacuum in here we have a flashlight we
have a car washer that you can also use
for other things and we have the
inflator which has a ton of options
built in now at the center of this is
their battery this thing is powerful
with more than double the capacity of
the lithium batteries compared to my
high-end power tools at home not only
that but you actually charge charge this
thing up with USB type c so no matter
where you're at if you're in the car you
can plug it in and charge it and with
that it also has a USB output with up to
18 Watts so you can actually plug in
your phone plug in your tablet and
charge it up if you need that and you
just have it with you and not only can
this battery charge my iPhone six times
but it also has a built-in flashlight in
here with multiple modes and I was
shocked by how bright it was along with
SOS light so there's a lot of features
that you can cycle through on the front
you see the battery capacity and one
super cool thing is how this thing
actually connects I connected it on
camera with one hand because it is
magnetic and so you don't have to lock
it in it's easy to use and the
connection is super strong now my truck
really needs some cleaning after our
crazy Winters and this thing has really
get suction it has multiple tips that
you can use so there's a fine tip you
also have a brush you can stack those
together and then to empty it very easy
you pop the front off pull out the
filter and empty the container so it's
really handy to have one of these now
with that it's always great to have a
flashlight and this thing is a high
brightness flashlight you guys see in
the clip it puts out a lot of light even
for my walls that are painted pitch
black with all the lights shut off
there's multiple modes and brightness
settings and it's rated up to 120 watts
which is crazy now inside the case you
have a couple different sections where
you can store things and one thing that
I was most interested in was the jump
starter now I already have a jump
starter but when my truck's battery died
I connected it and even 15 minutes later
it wouldn't jump same thing for a high
compression motorcycle where this is
actually rated for 700 amps has a peak
rate rating of a thousand two hundred
and it can jump start V8 trucks up to
seven liters diesel motors as well so it
is super powerful I actually jump
started my lawnmower with it because
it's been sitting all winter and it did
it instantly so just for the price tag
of something that's this powerful and it
can jump start up to 40 times that
already is a great value and I liked how
these clips right here they're perfectly
protected the little terminals where you
connect so you don't have to worry about
that and it gives you a light on here
when you are ready to jump start now my
next favorite thing is this inflator
first off once again I have to say how
durable this is made it is plastic but
it is thick very high quality plastic
feels super super durable has a lot of
weight to it and it comes with a bunch
of tips not only do you have your
standard inflator tip but you also have
a little tip to blow up things like
different balls and you have these
little nozzles if you're going to detail
your car or anything else that you need
to blow off which is nice and what I
really love is that on the back of this
you have a screen and you have a ton of
adjustments so you can go through PSI
bar different methods of you know
knowing the pressure and you can dial in
exactly the pressure that you need and
then once you press the trigger you
don't have to hold it down you literally
just leave it and it will pump up until
it's done or when you connect to a tire
say my kid's bike tire or anything else
you see exactly the pressure there so it
worked really well and when I was
testing it out I actually got a phone
call from a friend whose tire was flat
it was perfect timing I drove over there
I inflated his tire and it did a
phenomenal job so this thing is a
lifesaver and it's way better than those
cheap little pumps that take forever the
locking mechanism is excellent so this
is a life saver now the last tool in the
kit is this car washer it comes with a
hose as well as a nozzle that is
adjustable depending on the kind of
pressure that you want it's also battery
powered which is super handy has a quick
connection up here in the front it's
just the standard one and then you could
pressure wash your car you can soap it
up first and then you could wash it off
not only for a vehicle you can wash off
your sidewalk your house so if you need
something clean this thing is very
convenient so if you guys are looking
for a nice kit like this that you can
keep in the vehicle or in your house to
save you to make things really nice and
flexible and it's very easy to use you
guys can check out their Kickstarter
we're gonna have a link down below and
they have some awesome deals on there
where you can save a ton of money on a
kit that would cost you way way more
um compared to buying these individual
or from different brands even just the
jump starter itself is so powerful and
it works so quickly and easily so go
ahead and check them out and I'm going
to be keeping this in my truck because
it is so handy this has been a Max click
that Circle above to subscribe check out
one of those videos right over there and
I'll see you in the next one
foreign